und was könnte sich besser fühlen als
mit der fdp direkt weiter machen den
marco buschmann ist bei uns sehen ich
ihn vorhin schon mal vorgestellt habe
jetzt haben wir endlich zeit für das
gespräch das sie früher schon führen
wollte ich habe schon mal gesagt 92,3 9
prozent ist ein ziemlich starkes
ergebnis für die wiederwahl auch als
erster parlamentarischer geschäftsführer
wo liegen die herausforderungen für sie
in dieser neuen legislaturperiode die
fraktion ist um zwölf personen gewachsen
ja also wir freuen uns erstmal über den
zuwachs wir haben ganz tolle neue
kollegen dazu bekommen und die wollen
wir natürlich jetzt auch startklar
machen in dieser legislaturperiode
wollen wir regierungsverantwortung
übernehmen das wird die arbeit
hoffentlich auch prägen das ist
jedenfalls unser ziel und da wird es
darum gehen das land ins 21 jahrhundert
endlich zu führen den reformstau der
großen koalition aufzulösen das land
digitaler wettbewerbsfähiger und
nachhaltiger zu machen dh bei einem plus
von zwölf muss man sich jetzt noch nicht
so dramatisch umstellen als fraktion was
die organisation etc angeht doch schauen
sie wir waren voll schon eine moderne
transparente fraktion wir haben sehr
viele auch digitale tools verwendet die
sind skalierbar wie man so schön im
berater deutsch sagen würde also sprich
wir kriegen die neuen kollegen schon
schnell an die arbeit und auch schnell
eingebunden da bin ich mir sehr sicher
jedenfalls haben sich einige der neuen
kollegen schon gestern ganz herzlich für
die freundliche aufnahme und dass wir
ihnen ihr den start so leicht wie
möglich gemacht haben schon herzlich
bedankt das ist für mich ein signal dass
das ganz gut gelingen wird moderne
fraktion ist ein schönes stichwort die
grünen mit denen sie ja unter umständen
in welcher kombination dann auch immer
oder mit welchem kanzler auch immer ja
doch höchstwahrscheinlich koalieren
wollen und werden haben einen
frauenanteil von 59% die fraktion der
fdp liegt bei 24 prozent
ist das jetzt nicht langsam doch mal ein
argument über eine quote noch einmal
nachzudenken also ich glaube das thema
sehen wir das instrument halten wir
nicht für richtig wir sind bei den
wählerinnen und wählern immerhin genau
so aufgestellt wie die grünen da ist die
geschlechterparität genauso gut oder so
schlecht bisschen mit umgekehrten
vorzeichen aber das ist nicht sonderlich
auffällig und wir wollen natürlich jetzt
auch dafür sorgen dass unsere fraktion
auch in zukunft diverser wird und das
ist etwas woran wir arbeiten werden habe
sorgen macht uns das nie habe ich
erinnere mich korrigieren sie mich
notfalls vor ein paar jahren gab es mal
zielvereinbarungen für die verschiedenen
bereiche um den frauenanteil zu erhöhen
hier kann man sagen hat es nicht so
richtig begriffen ja das ist etwas was
die landesverbände mit ihren
untergliederung vereinbart auch mit dem
bundesverband
und das hat natürlich das ziel dauerhaft
an dieser zahl etwas zu tun aber wir
freuen uns jetzt erstmal wo die vielen
neuen kolleginnen und kollegen und das
wird uns großen spaß machen mit denen
durchzustarten und wie gesagt das
entscheidende sind ja nicht einzelne
kennziffern es entscheidend ist dass wir
das land voranbringen das ist ja unsere
aufgabe wir sind ja nicht hier für
statistiken sondern wir sind hier damit
deutschland digitaler wettbewerbsfähiger
und nachhaltiger das klingt jetzt nehmen
es mir nicht übel das klingt jetzt schon
so ein bisschen so als wenn ihnen der
frauenanteil doch ein bisschen egal wäre
in ihrer fraktion nein aber es ist ja
erst mal eine entscheidung der
wählerinnen und wähler und das ist nicht
sehr stark um entschuldigung ist ja
natürlich erstmal wie positioniere ich
frauen irgendwie was die kandidaten
angeht war solisten angeben programmen
müssten sie mit anderen leuten ein
gespräch führen als mit mir weil diese
kandidatenlisten werden ja von den
landesverbänden gemacht von den
landesparteitagen die sind demokratisch
legitimiert als parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer kann ich mir die
abgeordneten nicht aussuchen sondern die
abgeordneten suchen sich ihren
parlamentarischen geschäftsführer aus
und deshalb wird ich stehe jetzt wenig
zu sagen können gut aber so ganz ohne
einfluss sind sie natürlich in der
partei dann auch tatsächlich nicht 735
bundestagsabgeordnete wird diese
zwanzigste wahlperiode haben noch mal 24
mehr sie sind gescheitert zusammen mit
grünen und linken eine andere
wahlrechtsreform zu erreichen sie hatten
einen anderen gesetzentwurf vorgelegt
der mutmaßlich ein besseres ergebnis
gebracht hätte was die anzahl der
abgeordneten angeht nämlich deutlich
weniger und damit wahrscheinlich auch
ein möglicherweise arbeitsfähige hre spa
lament jetzt schauen wir uns mal an in
dieser hinsicht wäre doch ein
zusammenhang mit der union eigentlich
der falsche weg oder weil die hat ja im
grunde verhindert nein also die große
koalition hat gemeinsam die
wahlrechtsreform verbockt auch aus der
spd gab es ja zeitweise wirklich kuriose
äußerung ich kann mich erinnern an eine
kollegin der spd im plenum des deutschen
bundestages also nicht irgendwo im
plenum des deutschen bundestages gesagt
hat auch wieso mehr abgeordnete sind
doch mehr demokratie wo ist denn das
problem die also gar nicht das problem
erkannt hat dass das parlament nicht
arbeitsfähiger dadurch wird das ist auch
an legitimation einbüßt also die spd
hatte auch lange zeit einen
schlingerkurs und für uns steht eins
fest das ist leider
vergossene milch wir müssen ihnen dieser
legislaturperiode das wahlrecht
reformieren wir brauchen ein wahlrecht
das verfassungsfest ist und das
größenwachstum des deutschen bundestages
deckelt das ist eine top priorität in
dieser legislaturperiode und es wäre
schön wenn alle seriösen demokraten sich
daran beteiligen würden und sie denken
die union bewegt sich dann doch mal
naja es ist ja so im moment gibt es zwei
parteien die ist ganz gut finden wenn
sie das kanzleramt für sich hätten und
dafür mit fdp und grünen sprechen müssen
fdp und grüne vermutlich werden sich
sehr schnell einig sein weil wir es
bislang eben schon waren dass das
wahlrecht dringend reformiert werden
muss wir haben sogar einen gemeinsamen
gesetzentwurf dafür vorgeschlagen und
deshalb glaube ich sind die chancen sehr
gut dass sich da etwas zum besseren
bewegung
vor sondierungen ist ein neuer begriff
in der politischen landschaft das heißt
die beiden kleineren partner tauschen
sich untereinander schon aus können sie
bestätigen das was der spiegel meldet
dass das schon morgen stattfinden soll
mit den parteispitzen das kann und
möchte ich nicht weil ein wesentliches
element dieser vor sondierung ist ja
dass man vertrauen zueinander aufgebaut
dass man in ruhe sprechen kann dass man
vertraulich sprechen kann und deshalb
bestimmen diejenigen die an diesem
gespräch teilnehmen und das sind für uns
christian lindner und volker wissing der
vorsitzender generalsekretär wie sie
sich mit ihrem bundestreffen und das
machen sie in ruhe und vertraulich und
das ist glaube ich der beste weg um
vertrauen zueinander aufzubauen
es gab so ein bisschen rätselraten um
die pressekonferenz von armin laschet am
sonntagabend als er sich geäußert hat in
sachen dass er auch die union auf den
anspruch auf eine regierungsbildung
durchaus sehr haben sie ihn da am
sonntag so wie wir medien verstanden
oder haben sich die ihn am sonntag so
verstanden wie damit lassen sich selbst
verstanden hat weil er zwanghaft
versucht wieder so ein bisschen zu
korrigieren also wissen sie alle
parteien müssen selber sagen was sie
wollen es ist nicht meine aufgabe das
irgendwie zu interpretieren sondern wir
das land führen will muss sagen was er
möchte und wer eine regierung mit bilden
möchte muss selbstständig sagen was man
will wir würden uns als fdp ist auch
verbitten wenn man uns da hinein reden
würde sondern man muss in gesprächen
klar sagen was man möchte und das
geschieht dann auch nicht vor der kamera
sondern am besten in vertraulicher
atmosphäre
frage war er wie sie ihn verstanden
haben weil er ja dann wieder
zurückgerudert ist ach wissen sie die
cdu muss selber
herausbekommen was sie möchte das wird
sie hoffentlich spätestens heute tun und
dann warten wir mal ab was die einladung
oder ob es dann eine einladung geben
werde da keine einladung geben wird also
jetzt sollen erst mal alle parteien klar
machen was sie selber wollen für sich
wollen dann spricht man miteinander und
diese gespräche sind hoffentlich
erfolgreich und wenn man ein solches
erfolgreiches ergebnis hat dann gibt es
auch was zu erzählen marco buschmann
darauf freuen wir uns und darauf sind
wir gespannt und dann laden wir sie
wieder ein und dann gucken wir mal was
wir dann erfahren danke dass sie heute
bei uns gewesen sind bei uns war der
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführer
der fdp fraktion war in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode der auch in dieser
legislaturperiode sein und wird uns da
auf dem einen und anderen weg noch
begegnen